These frameworks typically all provide late binding,
persistence, encapsulation and sub-typing.
They provide support for communication among components including events,
channels and uniform data transfer mechanisms.
They also offer some form of component transfer packaging,
such as JavaJar files, ComCab files, or CLI assemblies.
They all provide a way of describing deployments such as via configuration file.
This description is also typically available at runtime via mechanisms such as
Reflection or metadata.
Any given framework provides a way of serving,
of serving components such as an application server model like EJB,
COM+ and CCM or web server models like JSP and ASP.Net.